welcome to the show that puts you at the
center of the national conversation
talking about the issues that matter to
you the most
tonight the National Grid has given us a
sobering warning that there could be
blackouts this winter
our government doesn't want to encourage
us to use less energy but grown-ups it's
not their business to order us around
they say let's trust can't control the
weather but is she leaving herself and
us at the mercy of the elements I'm
Trevor Phillips and this is the great
debate
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
each week we get to the heart of the
issue dominating the headlines the
National Grid responsible for keeping
the lights on has warned of the
possibility of rolling three hour
blackouts leaving us all to hope that
our demand for energy doesn't outstrip
Supply
this trust insists that Britain will
have enough to make it through the
colder months but ever since Russia
invaded Ukraine we've become acutely
aware of just how vulnerable we are
as ever our viewers panel from across
the country and then eat across the
world will tell us their stories they'll
have their say joining us in the studio
this week are
Catherine Porter energy consultant at
watt logic
Charles Hendry the former conservative
MP and former energy minister
Liam Norton from the pressure group
insulate Britain
and Tom gay Trex chief executive of the
nuclear industry Association
so let's take a look at the big question
tonight
energy crisis can we keep the lights on
this winter we are asking you to cut
down to the absolute minimum the use of
electricity for heating and for other
purposes in your home
hello
the possibility of energy rationing can
you rule that out Miss Truss I do rule
that up yes okay breaking news this hour
and households are to be paid to avoid
using electricity during Peak house this
winter this warning in a very worst case
scenario of planned blackout will be
alarming to many it is extremely
unlikely but it's only right that we
plan for every scenario
this is a damning indictment of
conservative policy over the last 12
years half a million roof tiles 250 000
bricks could be lost
much of Europe is taking part in energy
demand strategies reducing their demand
tell someone you know switch things off
for the national need when it makes no
difference to the National Security
position
[Music]
with our viewers panel and I'm going to
talk first of all to Angela and Stephen
Gilligan who are in Scotland
um Angela Stephen are you getting ready
for winter
absolutely Trevor
I'm old enough to remember the
percussive 70s Trevor it was miserable I
described as locked down in the cold
let's not just obvious everything else
so what do you anticipate
um having been through all of that and I
you know I don't want to admit to having
been there too but uh it was it was a
pretty uh heavy time
foreign
yes absolutely I think what we were
talking about is preparation uh we have
to well we've been told that it's not
going to happen but we've had that so
many times so we have to look at
practical advice and have things on hand
our experience from the 1970s of we
found out that just preparing will be
the way forward I think
um or in your preparation uh Angela
Stephen um what are you doing are you
getting uh warm clothes I mean um
what about are you getting out the
thermals
we're living in the west of Scotland we
already have thermals I've been a
thermal vest another Clues obviously for
the last few weeks
um our temperatures are much colder than
you have in the South and waiter and
living in the west of Scotland in
particular
so we generally are geared up for cooler
temperatures but obviously that's the
difference between you have
blackouts and you're in darkness and you
need to think right what are we going to
do to prepare so
having things at hand in a convenient
place because you forget especially in
the west of Scotland or Scotland no it's
very dark here our nights now we're dark
outside and if you have blackouts you
have no light whatsoever so if that was
to happen you've got to prepare torches
candles think ahead
well Angela and Stephen first of all can
I just say thank you that was the most
brilliant Public Service advertisement
I've seen in a long time thank you for
your experience let's let's go next to
Derek Watson Derek you're in Sunderland
um what's your thoughts about the
situation we're facing
well Trevor I do believe Liz trust is
fueling misinformation by blaming the
war in Ukraine for our energy crisis
when there is a bigger picture to this
all Russia only contributes four percent
of UK gas supplies we're deflecting from
the real issue
so my question to the panel would be is
it fair to blame the energy crisis on
the war in Ukraine
thank you Derek very direct question
there let's go to our panel Derek is
asking is it fair to blame the energy
crisis on the war in Ukraine Charles
Hendry it's absolutely the case that
that's the big factor this winter which
has changed things beyond recognition
from where we've been in previous years
that the government rightly made a
decision that we should stand with
Ukraine the British public have decided
that the government is right to do that
and therefore the government has to
insulate and protect the public from the
uh worst effects of those policies of
course we only do get about four percent
of our gas from Russia uh in fact that's
now been stopped but the biggest issue
of course is that Germany gets half of
its gas Russia sorry Italy gets 60 to 70
percent of its gas so that this is
having a knock-on effect across Europe
and our gas networks are all connected
we are not an island in energy terms we
have gas coming in from Norway from
Qatar and we've got pipes going into
Europe as well into Mainland Europe and
that was a choice that we made wasn't it
and actually we didn't for example we'll
come to the issue storage later we
didn't store gas we wanted to rely on
the broader Global Supply well that was
part of it historically we didn't need
so much storage because the North Sea
was our gas storage facility and if we
needed more we could get more out in a
response to the market situations so
that we do need more storage absolutely
and the mistakes have been made by
governments over many years not to go
down that route Catherine um would be be
in this situation without the Ukraine
war
yes we would in my opinion we're
actually experiencing two different
energy crises at the moment the crisis
in the gas market which is a result of
what's happening in Ukraine but we're
having a crisis in the electricity
market and that's a result of poor
policy and this is over decades it's not
just the current government it's
previous governments and other countries
have a similar issue
following a wind-led energy transition
without taking care of what happens when
it isn't windy is is the reason we're
going to struggle to meet demand within
the electricity Market this winter Tom
do you agree with this analysis of why
we're in a situation that we're in I do
I mean I think the points that Charles
was making
um actually explain the problem the
problem is that over the long term we
haven't properly planned to replace
um electricity generating capacity
that's been going offline and is going
offline now our new clearly Coal Fire
Stations gas fire power stations and we
have an adequately plan for that move
from fossil fuel being the dominant part
of our energy electricity mix to having
a much more low carbon mix it makes it
much more difficult for the National
Grid and it's made even more difficult
because a combination of factors it's
not just about Ukraine it's also about
looking at what's happening with for
example the ability to be able to import
from hydropower from uh from Scandinavia
when when water levels are low for
example there's a whole range of
different factors that making this a
very very tight winter but it wasn't
unpredictable in fact it was predicted
and we've ended up in a situation which
we really shouldn't have been in if
they've been proper planning about how
we run our Energy System and Liam do you
agree with this this but we'll come to
the issue of whether we can reduce our
use but do you agree with I think the
consensus here that there's been
a shortage of planning uh against
foreseeable risks
yeah I think I was on interviews last
year uh predicting an energy crisis as I
think many commentators were
um it's obvious that the war has had an
effect on NG prices that's obvious
um but I think we've seen Decades of
incompetence and I'd kind of argue
corruption almost from some successive
governments where they haven't been
interested uh in benefiting Ordinary
People but in benefiting Rich big
business incorporations and we're seeing
the consequences of that now let's go
back to our viewers panel and talk a bit
more about what this might mean for
people and talk to Jackie Mahoney Jackie
I know that both in your personal and
also in your professional life you're
pretty concerned
yes Trevor I am um I'm a social worker
and I work with um carer support workers
and I work with
um vulnerable people in the community
um myself and the carer support workers
who I work with provide essential
support to those most vulnerable in
society and my question is is how can we
be expected to help those in need on
their essential on essential visits when
so many people in my industry
particularly care support workers are on
low pay and struggling themselves
uh Jackie just to be clear for you is it
just a matter of money would that
be the the thing that helps
in term for me the um the the social
care system as a whole is is in a in a
crisis and in a critical State I think
um there's it's always where you spend
money so I think money needs to be more
targeted to those groups of people who
are going to be affected most if you are
going to recruit and retain people in
Social care as a a vital part of society
then you do need to attract those people
into the industry it's essential and
people are also reliant on key pieces of
equipment they're reliant on for their
own health that's oxygen machines
defibrillators
um all sorts of equipment that needs
electricity
um and warmth you know it cuts across
all age ranges okay
um Charles Henry uh
I think what Jackie is telling us is
that we're hearing stories about
blackouts and problems of Supply but
it's not just a problem of some people
feeling cold while they're watching the
Telly this is now a particular an issue
that could be a bigger problem for the
country in all sorts of ways I think
there's two different issues and I think
we you could see the audience reaction
to What Jackie was saying and the huge
amount of Sympathy for the circumstances
which he's in one is the physical
ability to keep the system operating and
if there's International shortages what
does that mean and the second is whether
people can afford to heat their homes
now the government has already moved to
address some of those issues but this is
a very scary winter for a very large
number of people and the government
needs to be willing to do more if that
is shown to be the case it could have
insulated homes it could have had a
national program going back months and
we could be going into this winter in a
much better prepared state for those who
are most vulnerable but it made
decisions not to do that and so it needs
to be willing to step up this is as I
said earlier we are in a war situation
and beholden on the government to make
sure that it does everything it can to
protect those who are most vulnerable
all right let me come back to Derek
Watson who asked the question about
whether
we can lay this at the uh at the feet as
it were of what the war in Ukraine
um Derek what's your view having heard
uh others on the viewers panel and those
in the studio
I think the one Ukraine does contribute
but I think the core issue is the
misinformation coming from the
government and when you have
misinformation you have a lack of trust
and when you have lack of trust there's
instability in the market and within
households across the UK and if if you
look to Europe Europe has a stronger
clearer message going out to their um
their their communities across their
countries particularly in France Germany
Spain Finland whereby it's almost
creating a national culture whereby it's
a together process in which people want
to work with the governments
save energy cooked on Cut Down on their
uses
um not just the um households but also
commercial businesses and dimming lights
reducing their energy costs I'm only
stopping you that Derek because you're
anticipating what we're going to talk
about next
this is the great debate up next
essential advice or a waste of money do
we need a government campaign to tell us
how to cut back
we have still not heard anything from
government around demand reduction
they're going to tell us what we have
what we'll do laundry we're not doing
spending 40 million pounds on a
government camping I don't think it's a
nanny state to offer practical advice
that people can choose to follow or not
I think it's just helpful
foreign
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're discussing the energy crisis can
we keep the lights on this winter
well unlike much of Europe our
government has ruled out a public
information campaign with tips to show
people how they can cut down their
energies as one Minister told me on Sky
News yesterday there's lots of
information on the internet and such
campaigns cost money
but will the government's horror being
seen as the nanny State just leave us
all more vulnerable this winter let's go
to our viewers panel and I'm going to
talk to Victoria
skulls Victoria uh do you think you know
what you need to know or would you
welcome a public information campaign
no they need to be a lot more
information
um I'm in a wheelchair
um and I'm use a lot of extra
electricity due to my disability
charging my power chair using my stair
lift there's a lack of information on
these things
I'm on the priority register with my
energy supplier
um so if the lights are turned out I'm
hoping I would be okay as I've been
advised but a lot of people don't know
that that help is out there for them
there's no mornings to be done
to show that that help is available to
them
shouldn't that be the job of the
suppliers Victoria
this applies you have to take some
information and feed it out but also the
government if they did a national
campaign get it out there then it's a
whole Nationwide they need to take
responsibility as they put us partly in
this situation to begin with all right
now you've got a question for our panel
coming out of all of that
yeah so it's do people need to take the
energy crisis more seriously thank you
very much Victorian I think in people
you also include
um our authorities the question is
should we be taking this crisis more
seriously Tom Great Tricks I think we
should I mean I think we've talked we've
talked a bit about the potential impact
in terms of Supply but in terms of use I
I not quite old enough to remember the
1970s travel like you but I did I'm able
to go onto YouTube and look back at some
of the campaigns that were done in the
70s and there was the Delia Smith
involved in the one that was about
energy senses common sense and it is to
some extent about those types of things
I just don't get this sense from the
government that they're really reluctant
to provide and help to amplify good
information things you can do that will
have an impact in terms of reducing your
costs of energy over the course this
winter so for example if you've got a
condensing boiler making sure the flow
temperature is at the right level is a
way of not affecting the amount of heat
you're going to be able to use but
actually significantly reducing your
energy so that's just one example and
there are a whole load of them now some
of us in this room will know about some
of them some of those in your audience
will know about some of them but a lot
of people won't know about any of them
at all and there's no I don't understand
this mentality from the himself saying
yesterday that spending 40 million
pounds at the same time as just the
biggest intervention ever in terms of uh
public financing for uh underwriting
energy bills for consumers and
businesses over the next few months it
just doesn't stack up I think it's
common sense to be able to help people
understand how they can be part of
making sure using energy wisely all
right well actually let's try something
let's see uh let's put what you've just
said to the test and I'm going to come
back to the viewers panel
um
I hope you're all paying attention uh
because I'm gonna I'm gonna do a little
quiz here
um I want to know
who amongst you knows how to lower the
temperature of your boiler how many of
you could go off after this program and
lower temperature you from your boiler
by let's say two degrees hands up who
knows how to do it
I am looking and thus far uh
you're all pretty you're all pretty
smart that's why we let you on the
program and I have to say
I don't know the answer to that question
by the way and probably about half of
you do Catherine what do you think
public information campaign or waste of
time
well I think I'm a bit torn on this
actually
um the situation in Europe is actually
quite different because they have an
outright need to reduce their energy
consumption I they have a real danger
although unless they have cold weather
this winter they probably can get
through with the gas they have available
the problem is next summer will they get
the gas they need to store up ahead of
next winter and so reducing overall
demand is really important
our issue in Britain isn't the same
we're not likely to run out of gas or
issues in electricity where we could run
out of electricity when it's not windy
and so our electricity system can be
overloaded for certain periods of time
and the behaviors that you need to
manage that risk are quite different
from the behaviors that you need for for
generally reducing energy consumption
that's all about moving your consumption
from one period to another and I think
if we get into that territory that we
need that sort of response from the
public then we need a campaign for that
at the time it's needed having it now
wouldn't really help and you'd run the
risk that people would get maybe a bit
bored with the whole thing that they
would get a bit fatigued with taking
these actions and then when it's really
needed they won't act so in January
February we might really need people to
reduce demand at particular times of the
day and really Target them with that
information so anyway rather than we did
with covert choose the moment for
Maximum Impact just quickly Liam do you
agree with that I think we need a public
information campaign to communicate
the risks of using fossil fuels and
that's what insulate Britain were
proposing last year we had a plan a
no-brainer plan which um would have
given best value for money in terms of
per pound spent and reducing the
country's emissions it would have uh you
know if you look at the ocean office of
national statistics last year before
this energy crisis was in the news
um they said that eight and a half
thousand elderly people froze to death
in their homes each year because they
couldn't afford to heat their homes it
would have eradicated millions of people
and brought them out of fuel poverty so
they didn't have to choose between
heating eating or or Essentials it would
have provided hundreds of thousands of
proper meaningful jobs it would have
boosted the economy of this country and
it's and it's been ignored but
ultimately what we need to do is
convince the general public that we need
to get off fossil fuels quickly because
we are within this in a catastrophic
climate Okay
we're going to come back to this issue
of reducing demand a bit later but in
fact I I did myself take The Minister's
advice and go to the government's
website to see if I could get some tips
about how I could save energy number one
the website kind of crashed but number
two what it essentially said is
um change your boiler and I'm going to
bring in somebody now
who has done that Phil Hinchcliffe who
um lives in East London Phil
um what was your experience of trying to
reduce your energy usage
I installed a heat pump in a Victorian
terraced house
and I paid within the region of 35
000 to 40 000 pounds to install a system
that will work as efficiently as
possible now for a heat pump to work
properly you need a large surface area
which runs at a cooler temperature than
your normal average gas boiler radiator
the result was
um I had to put in underfloor heating
everywhere in my house and as you can
imagine it's not cheap the heat pump
itself cost about 24 000 pounds of all
the bits and by the time I'd installed
everything it took me a year to finally
work out why the house was still cold
and basically if you run a heat pump in
a really well insulated house yes it
makes some sort of sense even in a well
insulated Victorian Terrace like mine
it's borderline and if you don't put in
underfloor Heating and you just use
radiators then heat pumps guzzle so much
electricity simply people aren't going
to be able to pay the electricity bill
wow uh I mean that is stay there Phil um
Liam that is expenditure I think
uh by my Reckoning about one and a half
times the average
British uh household annual income
worth it or not
I think is is I've done what you want
him to do insulate and all of that is is
uh saving our society from collapse
worth it I'd ask you that question do
you think it's worth it
heat pumps were all that's that's the
price that's what that's what we're
going to be doing we need to come off
fossil fuels this is the reality that
exists whether we like it or not that is
the situation that we exist within
um there's obvious challenges uh as the
gentleman describes and and they exist
all over the country it's an incredible
uh incredibly large project that we need
to undertake across the country but
they're still building the government is
still building new properties with gas
boilers in 2022 it's criminal after tax
that's the best part of two years income
for most people then that Charles is
that possible but just just quickly as
well like the government have just
borrowed 150 billion pounds and gonna
give it directly to energy companies and
that's going to in that's going to in
debt Ordinary People so that energy
companies can make more profit so where
do we want this public money to go to
well there are different low carbon
solutions for different houses and so
we've just moved house it's a barn
conversion we've looked to see whether
we could have a heat pump and they've
come and said no this house is too leaky
you've got to put in too many new
radiators it will be prohibitively
expensive exactly the same issue there
as we've just had but what we have got
is we've got solo we've got electric
radiators we will find other ways of
using Renewable Power to make our house
much more efficient and so it's not one
answer fits all we've got to have a
range of different solutions which are
increasingly out there and if you'll
allow me I'd want to come back on the
other earlier question which I didn't
get a chance to comment on which is
about the government information
campaign Derek said earlier that people
don't trust government and I think he's
probably right
I think it's important that we have a
campaign which is funded by government
but is delivered through citizen advice
or Martin Lewis or the local authorities
but through an organization and who are
trusted and people will listen to in a
way that they will believe what they're
being told and I also want to see
councils knocking on the doors supported
by Government funding of the people who
are most vulnerable to see what help
they can be given now to help them get
ready for the winter and be able to come
through it better this is the great
debate and in our next part
we're going to ask why Britain doesn't
store more of its own energy like other
European countries to see us through the
winter months
they've degraded our gas storage
facilities they've criticized solar
panels and Fields most countries in
Europe have got more gas storage
facilities than we have we do have a
good supply of energy in the UK we're in
a much better position than many other
countries
[Applause]
thank you
welcome back to the great debate where
we're discussing the energy crisis we're
asking can we keep the lights on this
winter
Britain is in some ways in a far more
fortunate position than the rest of
Europe because we don't rely as much on
Russian gas for our energy supplies we
heard earlier on but we do rely on our
neighbors importing large amounts of gas
from Norway and electricity from France
I'm going to talk to Andreas Erickson
Norway's Deputy energy energy Minister
good evening Mr Erickson thank you for
joining us
evening Sarah thank you for having me on
the program we read that Norway is uh
facing its own shortages right now why
uh Norway pumps massive amounts of oil
out of the sea and has hydroelectricity
why would you be suffering a shortage
well we basically don't use either oil
or gas for our own energy consumption
here in Norway we utilize as you
mentioned hydropower and this has been
the 20 in the driest hydrological season
in 21 years
so we have low Reservoir levels and
therefore a lack of energy also in our
system here in Norway
yeah I I understand that something like
85 percent of energy use in Norway comes
from hydro and that uh because of what
you've just explained you are going to
suffer a shortage now we do rely on you
for some of our energy uh can I just ask
you a direct question are we going to be
able to rely on you this winter
to help keep our lights on
absolutely uh I think we need to be able
to use our electricity in a smart manner
we have already seen conception levels
go down the last year we do everything
we can to keep the lights on both here
in Norway and then our neighboring
countries as well obviously our
hydropower role plays a crucial role as
a balancing power for the electricity
system for example also in countries
like the UK and we are going to maintain
that role throughout the winter
of course your experience does raise a
question which we've touched on already
in this program
everybody wants to get to Net Zero the
target here is 2050. uh
in order to do that we are going to rely
on changing the Energy Mix to introduce
more Renewables now you're virtually all
Renewables and you are still facing a
shortage uh is our policy
uh one that's going to stand the test of
time
I think we see that by connecting our
Energy Systems being able to secure
flows between countries the fact that we
can consume more electricity imported
from the UK when when it's a windy
evening in the UK and then save some of
that hydropower for hours where it's
crucially needed in both our countries
that is the way to go forward to be able
to balance out the system but we need to
ensure that we have enough power that
can be regulated to the times when it's
needed the most and that is a challenge
going forward that we have to face and
that we have to tackle if we are to go
fully renewable in Europe going forward
I get the point about base load is
essentially having a reliable uh
essential uh bottom level that's can't
be interrupted but of course if I may
just ask one last question
almost everything can be disrupted when
you have a Ukraine situation and uh I
suppose the the question uh to what
you've just said is that the more we
rely on the interconnectedness of energy
Supply the more vulnerable we are to a
Putin
I think what is happening in Europe now
is a very very grave situation uh the
reduced levels of gas from Russia and
the way that Russia utilized gas as a
strategic weapon has created an inner an
unprecedented energy crisis in Europe
but it is also an immense opportunity to
build a better and stronger system to
transition towards the green future that
we have been talking about for so long
and doing that together ensuring that
our systems work together actually makes
us more uh or better positioned to
tackle a crisis going forward as long as
we can trust each other as neighbors and
Friends
Andreas Erickson Deputy energy Minister
Norway thank you very much indeed for
your time
thank you
okay let's um let's pick that up
Catherine
um
as long as we can trust each other as
long as we can cooperate
realistic
well it's a very interesting question
because Norway's energy Minister stood
up in the Norwegian Parliament two weeks
ago and he commented on the fact that
countries like Germany and Belgium are
closing nuclear reactors early for
political reasons rather than because
they've reached the end of their lives
and at the same time they're putting
pressure on Norway to maintain its
electricity exports despite the problems
that we were just hearing about within
the Norwegian Market the Norwegian
government is going to be subsidizing
its consumers to up to 90 of their
energy bills this Wednesday
and this is very politically sensitive
in Norway and it's not unreasonable for
people in Norway to say well hang on a
minute we've invested in all this Hydro
capacity which we've paid for in our
taxes over the previous decades
now we've seen our prices go up 10 times
in the last year our taxes are now being
used for these huge subsidies and we're
exporting that benefit to other
countries that are failing to invest in
their own generation capacity in an
adequate way and even worse they're
closing perfectly functional capacity
because of some ideologies and
cross-border flows happen based on
really short-term price differentials
they ignore these wider policy decisions
that are still made at the national
level and I really wonder whether that's
going to be sustainable in the long term
some Great Tricks what do you think well
I you can't completely offshore energy
security and if you try to you end up in
the type of situation we're on the edge
of here the reality is you you need to
have a proportion of your power to be
completely
your own responsibility you need secure
reliable Supply
um look interconnectors can help but as
Catherine's just said the price signals
determine where the power goes up until
the point where that becomes politically
uh unsustainable in whichever country
whichever State and then I think you
will find then the pure economics and
the economic model that people talk
about in terms of interconnectors
becomes broken very very quickly and
that's why we have to make sure that we
have in the future our secure reliable
low carbon Supply is made up of the
right components to ensure we can get
through when it isn't windy enough we
can get through when there are
situations with gas supply we can get
through when there are problems
affecting the the amount of water in the
in the hydro infrastructure in Norway
for example well actually that takes us
on to uh what I think is a very
important point because getting through
doesn't just mean producing it means
storing and actually that has emerged as
something of an issue with our viewers
panel I want to talk to Dave McCormack
who has
um some experience in this area and has
raised this point about storage Dave
yeah a good evening Trevor I work for
years as a quarry manager supplying
Sands and gravels to go around
underground tanks for gas storage
and I can't understand why recent
governments have been so short-sighted
in their energy strategies
so my question to the panel or to
anybody is why did we do away with the
storage facilities for gas and oil
reserves both overground and underground
all around the UK
uh thank you very much Dave well there
is a a question which is going to come
to the panel why did we do away with our
storage facilities underground and
overground well Charles Hendry this was
in your hands when you're a minister
indeed and it's an issue which I've
campaigned about consistently so I try
to amend Labor's energy act in 2010 to
require more gas storage I tried to
amend the coalition's infrastructure act
in 2015 with Tom supporting me uh for to
require more gas storage and we've had a
number of very close runs in the winter
on our gas supplies we had the langolid
pipeline from Norway freezing up one
year we had a winter which ran on radio
well into April almost into May we've
seen the threat by the Iranians to
blockade The Straits of her moves which
would stop all Qatari gas coming through
it's in previous disputes between Russia
and Ukraine and my view is you cannot
rely on luck and that in a number of
years we have been so close one year
within hours of running out of gas and
that therefore we should have been
taking long-term strategic decisions to
require more gas storage to be built
there's a the point which was made there
which was our main gas storage facility
was closed down by centrica in 2017 I
think and that was a commercial decision
but the government could have stopped it
Greg Clark the Secretary of State could
have said no we will step in my view is
you actually be fair it wasn't a
Whimsical decision was it was it
centrica basically said look it's going
to cost a fortune to keep this storage
which is of like in a vast tank under
the North Sea kit to keep this in uh in
shape so it doesn't blow up and that
we're moving away from fossil fuels why
would we want to keep this vast storage
facility when actually we don't want to
store this stuff anyway well because we
all know we need gas as a transition
fuel even though we're investing in
Renewables we're still going to need gas
and therefore if we're going to do that
in a secure way we've got to have more
more gas storage we're going to move on
this is the great debate
after the break what does the future
look like for our energy Supply
did we make a bet on going green that
might not pay off
it is important that we use all
available sources of fuel within this
country
we have 50 years worth of UK gas supply
sitting under the north of England
you must phase out fossil fuels full
stop
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're discussing the energy crisis and
asking can we keep the lights on this
winter
oh I know there's a lot of potential in
renewable energy but the wind doesn't
always blow and the sun won't shine
every day it's clear that a move to
Renewables will increase our energy
security but can that transition be done
without relying on oil and gas
let's talk to Stephen Fairley in
Bathgate in Scotland good evening
Stephen what's your view on this
the question I was one was is it the
right time to increase the use of fossil
fuels and [ __ ] when we should be
looking to be in our future all right
Stephen's question for the panel uh is
is it the right time to increase the use
of fossil fuels
tell them Great Tricks no I think what
we should be doing is everything we can
to reduce the amount of fossil fuels
half of our electricity currently comes
from fossil fuels you can see the impact
that has in terms of prices at the
moment if we built more low carbon
capacity earlier we wouldn't be facing
quite as extreme situation as we are now
so you know the nuclear power station
like Hinckley have been built earlier if
it's operating now that would save the
equivalent of more than three billion
pounds to the consumer just in one year
so it shows you the fact that energy
instability and dirty energy and
insecure energy are all solved by doing
the same thing which is reducing the
amount of fossil fuels we're using to
burn for electricity and increase the
amount of different low carbon sources
to get the mix that gives us a secure
and reliable Supply Catherine um I think
you refer you spoke about transition
earlier on
um how do you how would you respond to
Stephen's question I mean I actually
unfortunately disagree with Tom I think
that we've reached a position in our
energy transition where our energy
security is at risk and I think what
people forget is that energy insecurity
costs lives and when energy is too
expensive that also costs lives so it's
not just climate change that costs lives
and the reason that we talked about the
energy trilemma was that was we were
recognizing those things and in recent
years we've forgotten we forgot that we
need to maintain energy security so if
you have blackouts in the winter traffic
lights and street lights go off people's
lives are at risk immediately people who
have medical equipment in their homes
that need electricity their lives are
put at risk when people can't afford to
heat their homes their lives are put at
risk so we have to have a balance of all
these things and we do not have the
capability right now to manage the
intermittency of wind and the only way
that we can fill that in the short term
is through fossil fuels so talking about
building more wind turbines so it
doesn't help you if it's not windy those
extra wind turbines will all just sit
there not doing anything Charles entry I
think I can find a compromise between
these two which is that in the short
term we may well need to use more gas as
backup as we go through the transition
then we have to move even more quickly
in a low carbon Direction we've got
small modular reactors very exciting
nuclear technologies coming through
we've got hydrogen I think you should be
using tidal we should be doing much more
on Energy Efficiency there's a whole
range of areas where the future I think
looks very green and very exciting but
we've got to get through this current
crisis and then we need to have gas as
part of that I don't think fracking is
the answer the UK government has said
its web communities want it there isn't
going to be a single one which wants it
but I think that we do need to be making
sure that we can then accelerate more
quickly Liam do you think Charles is uh
program is the way through
I think um from from what I understand
we have enough oil and gas to get us
through the next eight years
um it's a completely immoral situation
for a government to be preparing
licensing for over 130 new oil and gas
projects which is what it's currently
doing and that's why in Chile Britain is
supporting the Justice oil Coalition who
are out in London at the moment in civil
resistance against the criminal
government who are out to destroy the
very fabric of our society it's treason
yeah well they're committing treason
upon the people of this country
uh I think there's some there's some
reaction to that but let's just go find
if I may to Jackie skip uh on the
discussion as a whole Jackie
I mean rugby what's your thought
S I just don't think we can ever abandon
that zero
um and I think we're regularly watching
the horrors of climate change reach on
Australia and this just massively
outweighs any problems we're facing now
okay Jackie you have given us a real
hard Choice here and I'm going to put
this hard choice to our viewers panel
even if it means for example
uh these rolling blackouts even if it
means that we're gonna have to pay more
for boilers and so on the things we've
been discussing tonight
I would like those who think that in
spite of all of that we must still stick
to the Net Zero by 2050 Target those who
still think that that Target is both
desirable and achievable and we should
stick to it
I am seeing those who want to throw your
hands up okay and those you can put your
hands down and those who think that
actually
that may not any longer be an absolute
100 priority that we need to stick to
those who think Net Zero
in the face of what we've uh what we're
looking at may have to be put back
okay I think there's still a majority
for sticking with Net Zero
thank you
and that is all we have time for this
evening it just remains for me to say
thank you to our panelists here in the
studio from great tracks Charles Henry
Liam Norton and Catherine Porter
of course as always it's you at home Who
Remain at the center of our conversation
and if you'd like to be part of the
program next time you can get in touch
by emailing the great debate at Sky dot
UK
and for now I want to thank you our
viewers panel for your thoughtful
spirited contributions yep
and also to thank all of you for
watching uh at home keep talking and
we'll see you again at the same time
next week for the great debate
[Music]
[Applause]